pendant les vacances d'été l'association
de la ligue de sport adapté de saint
denis organise une colonie de vacances
pour les personnes majeures porteurs de
handicap psychique
pendant trois semaines ryad freddy
agathe et tous leurs compagnons ont
participé à des activités de loisirs
ce matin c'est le dernier jour de la
colonie toute l'équipe prépare une
exposition des photos prises pendant les
trois semaines
au niveau de l'activité manuelle on a
jonglé entre
argile le plâtre après les matins on
faisait des activités sportif on a aussi
fait des rondes au milieu d'eux fera par
son maillot soit sortie vous brûler ou
volcan n'avait les sorties culturelles
aussi mais toujours de sortir à ce monde
les personnes porteuses de déficience
psychique sont encadrés par une équipe
d'animateurs et de bénévoles sans qui
rien ne pourrait se faire
le savoir faire de l'association est
avant tout le sport adapté aux personnes
handicapées
mais face à la demande croissante des
familles qui souhaitent leur trouver une
activité pendant le temps de vacances
scolaires l'association a développé ce
projet soutenu par la ville de saint
denis et le conseil général de man le
sud et des parents
la pathologie il faut être vraiment 24
heures sur 24 en présence et un parent à
l'annoncé s'est vu passer aussi
ils sont en attente d'être données
spécialisées certains ne trouveront
jamais de traces de sang avaient
accueilli il y en a qui sont là depuis
une dizaine d'années parce que ya pas de
place nous nous empressons pas
sélectionnable je sais pas comment ça se
passe
ou alors ils sont là départ on vous dit
que c'est qu'on se déposent nous
ramassions où je rentre à la maison
jusqu'à ce soir 16 heures
je pense que c'est un besoin de
récupérer les autres étudiants moi je
prends le bus je fais un tour en ville
se fait l'art martial delaire 400 pages
de monde je descends je me prends le
temps du magasin avec avait dès demain
pratiquement impossible passé pour tenir
par la main et veillées qui tout ça
riait et avec les éventuels cruises qui
peut avoir recevait donc le parent que
souvent il est tout seul et c'est dur
ici pas de soignants de professionnels
du médico social
mais tout se fait avec une conscience
aiguë du besoin de considération ma
pratique à venir pour tout à fait du
foot et là
quoi marche pas qu'est ce que tu manges
pas encore
est ce
bien souvent on dit ouais mon gamin il
handicapé on donne ce procès tendances
et des pourcentages à 10 20 40 50 pose
en a besoin
nous on s'en fout de 2 81% montfort
c'est ce que les 20 qui restent qui nous
intéresse c'est ce vers la cedh 10 et 40
qui reste qu'on essaie de développer de
de finaliser le truc pour que la voie la
pause ici s'il veut pas utiliser tout ça
mais je vous signale dans votre
désaccord ont eu au moins une relation
de faire et la compétence leader avec ce
qui nous reste
et puis comme il craint l'aimé pas trop
trop trop parlé et quand on rentre dans
son son nom peut on peut communiquer
avec lui parfaitement donc le c'est vrai
françois oui c'est vrai j'aime bien
bockel a permis de voilà un ministre
porte attention toutes les activités
sont mises en place à partir des choix
et mis dans les participants pas
proposer une activité si comme ça il
faut qu'il choisisse pour qu'ils
s'intéressent donc il se sent acteurs de
ce qu'il faille
on fait tout le cas raison parce qu'ils
viennent nous faut la monter dans une
voiture vitesse moto les bleus
retrouvent avec des amis
tout est malade après tout cet après
midi c'est karaoké une activité proposée
par freddy qui est concerné par les
troubles autistiques toute l'équipe
adhère à la proposition
non
m
et quand ces jeux qui était à terre
chez vous
trois semaines de vacances où chacun se
sent pris en compte et partage ses
activités cela crée des liens de
camaraderie les mythes dès la rentrée à
chacun reprendra son rythme de la vie
quotidienne pour sa part l'association
propose des ateliers occupationnels
trois jours par semaine et continue par
ailleurs son action sportive et
travaille au développement de son
activité
ch.d
oui
non